Let's go maybe to a local call or from the
five Oh eight area code.
Who's calling today from five oh eight
hey, it's Brandon.
How you doing?
Hey Brandon, where are you calling from?
I am in the new ones on air.
I don't really want to get my location but
I don't tell you that
it's not Brockton is it?
Please tell me it's not Brockton.
Yeah, it is definitely not wrong.
Okay.
Brockton's
fine.
I'm, I'm half kidding, but I just saw five
away.
What's on your mind today?
Yeah, so, um, I'm kind of a unique color.
I, I grew up in a conservative type family,
grew up conservative myself, uh, through college.
And then during college I joined the military,
um, was in the military for awhile while being
in college.
And then I, right now I'm a full time police
officer.
So why I think, cause I'm definitely, I feel
like I'm in a unique situation.
I used to be very conservative and now I'm
super left-leaning I guess.
Um, and, and within two jobs or two career
paths that I find that are very conservative,
so I find myself all the time, you know, debating
these, these issues.
You know, when your show with Kyle show that
was mentioned before and I don't know, I just
find, I don't see many people out there who,
you know, fit my description who feel the
same way.
You know?
That's interesting.
I mean you don't without you, you know, you
don't have to say where you are, but I think
there's a lot of places in the five Oh eight
area code, which even though they're in Massachusetts,
they're relatively blue collar conservative
places.
So it, I'm not shocked to hear that the majority
of the people in law enforcement are relatively
conservative since I think my instinct is
from people I know, whatever, like the politics
are of a place, law enforcement is always
slightly to the right of that.
So like as a counter example in North Hampton,
Massachusetts where the show started, which
is a very left leaning place, the police department
is still quite left leaning.
The police chief right now is um, uh, is a
lesbian officer and the police participate
in the pride parade and all this stuff, but
still like in general that that police force
is still to the right of North Hampton, Massachusetts,
if that makes sense.
So I'm not super surprised to hear that.
Right.
Yeah.
I just, it's funny cause I was at, you know,
work, um, the other night and I, you know,
everyone's thought assumed that because, you
know, I was police officer that I, you know,
I felt, or I had my political, you know, I
lead.
Right.
Yup.
Um, which is the opposite of the case.
Right.
So I don't know, I just, I just, you know,
I, I like talking politics and like political
junkie and I love the stuff, but I dunno,
I just, I just haven't found anyone else really
who feels the same way, at least in my, you
know, in my demographic.
Yeah.
I mean I think I would look at some of the
departments out in western mass.
I mean, but does this cause, does this cause
problems for you with your coworkers?
Um, absolutely not.
Cause I find, I find them really educated
about, um, politics and stuff like that.
And they are very stuck into identity politics
and, you know, whatever the president says
is like, you know, is right.
And, yeah, that's just kind of like the, you
know, the debates we have.
And I'm known as like, you know, the more
liberal police officer.
But no, I just want to also say, cause I know
you get a lot of, um, people that listen to
your show that, you know, we are, you know,
people in law enforcement are out there and
we all, we do, you know, there are some of
us that do things this way.
So, you know, I just wanted to kind of make
that known as well.
Thank you.
Yeah.
And we have many a left-leaning law enforcement
current and former folks in the membership
as well.
Um, so I appreciate the phone call.
Yeah.
Thank you Debbie.
All right, take care.
And on that note, we will go to a break.
Uh, thanks to everybody that called in, uh,
many, many more stories to discuss coming
up nights.